each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
does Katherine Tucker who is visiting us
from the distant reaches of MIT Sloan
School of Business and I think this will
be a really perfect top for this lab
since I've been here discussions about
privacy have been some of the most
interesting ones that I've listened to
because there are so many people here
who have such diverse perspectives on
privacy and given that she's the only
people who maybe had less of an interest
in that were the biology people but
they're interested in this as well is
this about medical privacy and not
another type of privacy so I really
think this is a great example of
something that spans the interests of
the labs and hopefully we'll get a
lively discussion take wait oh thank you
very much so um when I was invited here
today I probably wrestle what a lot of
your speakers you know wrestling where
shall I have some greatest hits or
presenter paper and I thought usually it
goes best if you present a paper arm but
I've also actually just mentioned I've
done work on surveillance privacy and
advertising markets and so I'm just
highlighting that should we run out of
things to say about this paper in of us
so this is joint work with amalia miller
who is a health economist at the
university of virginia and what we're
going to ask in this paper is what kind
of privacy protections encourage or
discourage the spread of personalized
medicine now you know it seems like a
straightforward research question but I
just want to get us all on the same page
about what these terms make so what I'll
do is first of all take you through what
i mean by personalized medicine and then
talk you through what i mean when i say
different kinds of privacy protections
okay so what is personalized medicine is
basically using someone's genetic
medicine to first of all understand
their likely subset ability to a disease
understanding how bad or how long the
disease is going to be if
it happens and also understanding how
different courses of treatment might
affect um might have effective they may
be and indeed if you're one of these
people who worries about the cost of
healthcare in the US this seems like to
be you know an obvious Avenue to go down
craig venter I've got a quote from him
here saying that um drugs and general
only work on about thirty percent of the
population and that variation can often
be explained by the underlying genetic
differences in genetics now obviously he
is not a disinterested party we're going
to talk a bit about you know how
effective these treatments really are
but that's the underlying idea so I give
you that idea and people sort of fig
they know what I mean but I I always
find it helpful to put it also still
show this picture remind you that of you
know recent news story which is Angelina
Jolie had this kind of personalized
medicine when she took a genetic test
which revealed she had a bit brca1
mutation which meant she was very likely
to get breast ovarian cancer as a result
she had a double mastectomy and a
hysterectomy so if you're so we sort of
see there the potential for personalized
medicine right we find out you're likely
to get this disease and if it happens
it's likely to kill you and you can take
action though it tends to be somewhat
dramatic often and somewhat more severe
that we might recommend to the average
person okay so that's the basic idea
between Jan out here personalized
medicine and genetic testing my next
question for the audience is who has
actually done a 23andme test whoa three
people you have
okay wonderful so we got 22 who actually
this is their job and you is this your
job to know this was just fun that's
just for fun okay so um I do have to ask
this because of the talk and where we
are um how much time did you think about
the privacy implications of taking that
test not very long okay interesting
interesting well we're so cool you out
on that let decision to not worry about
the privacy implications later on you're
worried such an inner Neil Heslin from
someone so young oh okay so anyway the
reason I'm saying this it's not we're in
this room dare I say we've got some of
the most so tech geeky advanced Winky
wish all of these kind of things right
we know the human genome project
finished in 2003 why haven't we also
done this er these kind of tests um well
first of all the questions over efficacy
which I imagine you know very well and
there's sort ? and of data mining we've
done at the moment how informative or
practical or predictive it really is and
the other second part of this is that
sometimes there are some diseases where
we probably do know about genetic
markers such as Huntington disease where
if you find out you've got them it's not
really quite clear what you're going to
do from a medical perspective apart from
go out and buy the best life insurance
you can right arm so those are these
twin questions first of all how a liable
is it and there are also lots of
questions over what really can we do if
we find out from your genetic matter
what you're going to die off the second
thing so conditioned education I made
potentially the mistake of giving this
talk in the Cleveland Clinic very senior
doctors there they were just
laughing at the idea that this could be
at all important or relevant given
relatives their expertise and you know
it's this is not unusual for many
healthcare technologies when we're
trying to think about the spread of it
clinician education and changing opinion
leaders and how they do practice tends
to be a big barrier so having that's
unusual reimbursement of course for all
these reasons we're not seeing
reimbursement in general though these
are pretty common questions for any kind
of new health care technique when I'm
going to be focusing on this talk are
the patient privacy concerns i want to
so highlight these exist but focus on
this talk on the idea that different
kinds of papers from privacy concerns
may also be limiting the spread of these
tests oh not you great so they're so
test set up this framework for privacy
protections and in general for something
about genetic matter or a genetic or
creating a digital record of your human
genome which evokes great privacy
concerns and so to just give you an
example I actually did the 23andme test
and I found out you know if you believe
this or not that the data or not that I
have got a far far higher by orders of
magnitude chance of having macular
degeneration later in my life now I can
say that because I'm a tenured professor
at MIT and what really can they do he's
like no she shouldn't say that but maybe
I should but you know I'm gonna really I
mean little you know if you've tried to
figure someone who can say that in
public maybe I'm in it in a reasonably
privileged position but for my trip but
it sort of brings like these issues
first of all you know we can actually
find potentially information which may
have damaging implications for our
employability and what's more the
implications for employability aren't
now it's not how we sort of think about
privacy protections when it comes to
advertising instead all the privacy
implications are in a world 20 to 30
years down the line I'm
maybe while you're shaking the head is
by that time I mighty won't exists and
you know you know it will be replaced by
MOOCs I don't know anyway okay okay so
that's exactly what I'm going to be
studying where the restrictions on how
far this information can be shared
encourage people to take these tests you
okay okay that is a really interesting
point i'll show you some of the text of
some of the disclosure documents when
i've read the laws they fail to make
that distinction and usually the laws
are around an idea of a genetic record
rather the existence of a genetic record
so my the routes at this point is
regulation is not up to your level of
iterative thinking right now others
didn't even higher level of iterative
making which is that even existence this
is a possibility so I'm gonna we're
going to have there going to be some
laws which people who still share your
concerns have tried to implement and
some some states have taken steps to
have a law which says if you're an
employer for example you can't use this
information in making hiring decisions
i'm going to show you that from the
consumer perspective maybe because these
laws are not well understood they're not
going to make much of a difference ok so
again just before we get to sort of more
data because it's going to be a very
much a data piece
wanted to highlight that you know as
they were known as privacy concerns are
not just unique to your own ethics arm
instead um we probably have and this is
I want to be clear and over the
simplification in general we have three
very different approaches potentially i
think for intellectual point of view in
terms of regulating privacy and the
first we might think of as an informed
consent this has been the approach arm
very much promoted by the OECD and the
EU in the original EU privacy directives
armed with the idea that one way we
should think about privacy is regulating
how people know whether people what
people know about how their data is
going to be used so that when they
consent they know what they're
consenting there's going to be
regulating data use and again this is so
stylized but often the u.s. we've taken
this approach to thinking about
regulating privacy think about credit
reporting and so on um and thirdly
there's sort of the more supposin or
economics approach which is saying well
maybe one way of thinking about privacy
is that we have an absence of property
rights and as a result perhaps what
we're missing here is still clarity of a
property rights now you'll notice I've
put lots of question marks here and the
reason I did that is because I saw try
to say once bit like the EU one's a bit
like the US and one's a bit economist
Fantasyland and I did this and then I
was actually presenting this work in
France and the government people that I
wanted to make very clear that fronts
does everything right they will do
everything to protect privacy and then I
shouldn't just say that they do one
thing I do they're going to regulate
privacy United United to infinity so so
take this is a very stylized idea but
what's going to be nice about this
genetic setting is that because states
don't know how to regulate this kind of
data we're going to see attempts to do
all three in different combinations
and that's going to give us maybe more
of a you know an interesting laboratory
I hate to source a to try and think well
how do different privacy regulations
work okay um last thing to say before we
get on to the regression work is that
and this is why we're taking and perhaps
more to an argument which is familiar to
the biologists here is this question of
why enough are we treating genetic data
as something special and private or
someone help privilege um and this is an
argument you know dominated I think by
you know so jurisprudence scholars and
the argument is well should we think
that genetic data even needs any special
protections um I thought there was some
kind of convincing arguments this is
sort of genetic information uniquely
powerful argument but I and then there's
the idea what you do it it's going to be
created for ever say with advertising
right I can have been bankrupt once
search of bankruptcy wants it might be
very different in ten years time with
genetic data is going to be the same
genetic code basically and I think the
other sort of good argument for me is
the implications for family members
right what happens if me talking about
my macular degeneration these people to
so look at my sister and say oh maybe
how eyesight's going to go to UM the
other you know having said that still be
balanced um really its genetic
information that data different or much
more severe from regular medical data I
mean I challenged you to sort of think
well is it really worse have your
genetic code out there relative to say
having a positive HIV test that's not
quite clear to me um and I think in
general is just sort of an air of we
don't really know what this is yet
should we be teaching it as exceptional
before we actually know so all of this
sort of introduction is actually going
to lead me to a more refined version
right as an issue a search question
which is what we're going to do
is I'm going to look to see what kind of
privacy protections and this is going to
be the US state level encourage or
discourage the spread of hospital
genetic testing for cancer and why they
focusing on Hospital genetic testing for
cancer wellness with more mainstream
ward brushed anemic tests well because
here this is an area where you actually
have the potential for effective and
useful treatments so for example as in
the angelina jolie jolie case if you're
found to having genetic susceptibility
to cancer they were drastic actions you
can take such as the removal of
potentially cancerous tissue preventive
radiation therapy these kind of things
so there isn't a sort of lingering doubt
about what do we actually do with this
information I think I could actually
sort of say this is probably a useful
test potentially to take and we're going
to add to it the soil general set of
questions do we really see any different
from attempts to regulate genetic
privacy relative to the regulation and
general of health data are there is
there any evidence in the data for these
genetic exceptionalism arguments so I'll
consumers perceiving it as somehow
different in needing different
protections so that's what we're going
on any questions or clarity before we go
in two numbers so if not let's go into
numbers and start looking at these
privacy laws was what you're about to
see is incredibly straightforward
standard juice form policy evaluation
work so Greg zueitina d he knows where
this going um okay so it's very as I say
I was not making up when I said that
states have been playing around with
genetic privacy regulations right ever
since you and Dino project and you know
is was conceived states have been
thinking about how to regulate this
they've introduced different laws at
different times there have been a few
states where we've seen law actually
change over time and then
done this in different combinations and
so that's going to be the variation the
data I'm going to exploit I we have
tried of course because this is reduced
form econometrics work you're gradually
going to be asking yourself well is that
really exogenous can we believe that
this is not just reflective or
underlying state characteristics I'm
going to try and present some reassuring
evidence we dug into why these laws
happen what you tend to find is as one
state senator somewhere who gets a bee
in his bonnet so I think we're sort of
worrying more about systematic variation
of that senator well on something more
systematic that's used to be the origin
of most of these laws so those states
have not yet regulated state privacy in
2008 which is going to be part of my
data period the federal government is
going to come in and provide some very
baseline protections and so I think that
preempted some of us maybe the smaller
states from acting oh I see okay so if
we're having a biopsy in some ways it's
going to tell you whether you have
cancer right now whereas if I do a
genetic test we're going to find out
about your likelihood of developing
cancer later in life yeah so that's so
basically the difference is so if you
get a biopsy of count so you're going to
go straight to go start radiation
treatment for genetic test you're going
to start removing cancerous trips or
probably if you have a positive result
ok so the source of data is going to be
a series of pre NIH so CDC basically
surveys which are part of a broader
server they do on cancer patients and
and cancer treatment and in three years
2000-2005 2010 which fortuitously
overlay these periods where states were
experimenting with these different laws
they're going to ask questions about
genetic testing but you should see right
away from a data point of view we're
going to have a repeated cross-section
and so you don't have that in mind um
now they have quite a few data 34
responses in general so we have some
some sample size and being a CDC effort
they over sample from people who might
get cancer and then try and correct that
with weights and so all the results i'm
going to report to you or based on ways
the way to results um so it is a great
thing about this data is first we'll
actually also about genetic test it does
so in a representative large national
sample the big negative for me and maybe
some of you won't have any sympathy with
this is tall lisanna usually works on
questions of electronic commerce I found
it incredibly difficult to have to go to
this locked room already know what
regressions I'm going to run give the
code in you know and then you know have
everything scrutinized um I guess the
good thing from your point of view is
that you know i'm not being selective
about my regressions right side order
can play um so I think you know the
other good thing is that they were
asking about the testing of actionable
type of cancers which is good from sort
of you know trying to say whether or not
these we care about the results the big
con and i want to emphasize this I can't
do anything about it it's the state of
the technology not so many people are
taking these genetic tests right think
about this room writ large with less
people fewer people studying 23andme we
have sort of one person in the room
there's not that many people and so
we're just going to be dealing with
fractions of percentage point in two
thousand it's going to raise rise a
little bit by 2010
but you're where you should think about
all these results is that this is a very
early stage of this technology and
therefore we'll talk about a little bit
later but it's not quite clear how
anything generalizes um sort of like you
know another pro and con they say we're
looking at hospitals because we wanted
to test where we could say positively
this is probably a good thing to spread
um the coin is you know in the broader
world maybe were interested in questions
of firms like 24 your men we don't have
any data on that okay and the other nice
thing about this data said is we could
at least know a lot about the people in
it elect a lot of other controls which
we're going to use to control for all
the general things you might affect
think it would affect the decision to
take a genetic test I'm trying to work
out how much of this about individuals
making decisions decisions okay so
mm-hmm so I I've got some data which is
going to help for this um the decision
to actually take the test and the reason
that privacy policies are going to be
relevant is that before you take any one
of these tests for whatever reason
you're going to have something they
called genetic council where someone is
going to walk you through the
implications and the privacy policy in
detail that you're going to be that your
data is going to be stored under now you
exactly right and I'll show you some
results that there's going to be a lot
of factors including probably the doctor
knowledge of these tests general
education which are going to affect the
decision as you'd expect but I'm sort of
looking at that intervention Midway um
in genetic testing the thing that's been
around the whole time
so this is this so in two thousand as i
said the two thousand free the genome
was Matt this was the first part they
basically did and it's the reason I like
to start you know it feels like a
reasonable dependent variable is that
they've been enough articles for you to
think this is actually predictive of the
fact you're going to get cancer if you
have one of these gene mutations that
testicle oh I'm sort of just testing
bracha one like very targeted genes
versus like of a whole team Oh like
privacy concerns and everything they're
quite different okay so this is where
this will be my explanation you can may
be translated into medical terms so the
focus of these tests and the result they
are focusing on is going to be for
specific gene mutations the issue then
comes that you have your jeanette
digital genetic matter is now going to
be part of the record even if they
haven't specifically tried to correlate
it with any outcome or not sometimes
people get a targeted like bracha one
rocket to test and they're literally
don't know the rest of the genome and in
other cases they measure the whole
genome but only look at part of it so is
the latter that we should think about i
think is happy it from what I understand
from the doctors that's what happened
was happening answer stupid slingback a
jeans it's a thousand times more
expensive is it was told you know I
right but I think most are denied i'm
not sure but i would have thought that
most the tests in these all especially
when the previous years like most people
aren't being sequenced until now in
clinical practice like i'm at this year
last year so five years ago i would
imagine most of these actually was not
most of the genome actually like was not
up and measured is do you know like as
I've never um so again I am going to go
with what I was told which over the
course of the last ten years one's
ability to measure and understand what
we see in the sequence has increased you
know obviously expand
actually however the fact that the data
was created in whatever year doesn't
mean you couldn't go retrospectively it
was created I guess yes so that's what I
understand it is being created perhaps
because you're saying because of these
cost concerns at least that's what I was
told for me things targeted bracket
wanted to probably Sanger sequencing so
you also do a two genes right now there
are 20,000 genes the genome the ax
sequence data will be generated for like
two of them and the other 20,000 so
genes will not be assayed much the times
it's much more expensive and impractical
in 2003 human genome the first foal cam
with sequence two no three packaging
rack mutations as a cause of breast
cancer discovered appointed 90 mmhmm
yeah i mean i think i'll show you some
of the consent policies right the the
way they're written would at least give
a patient to understand that it's not
just the specific mutation which has
been analyzed but instead the entire the
entire data is being stored good point
excellent okay so let's go to some sort
of at some general summary statistics
and um part of it consol goes to Gregg's
question only forty-three percent of
these people are gonna hurt you know
that test right let me tell you that's
actually going to be a very influential
factor on whether you have one though
not as deterministic as you anything um
so this is going from two thousand two
thousand and ten those two thousand but
we gotta I said we got across this is
just an average across the data yeah I
mean we can sort of you know you can
sort of thing at the standard deviation
potentially is measuring that over time
we saw yes the direction um-hum the
other thing I want to do so look at is
that these are think of these has been
the proportions of these different kind
of laws
um and you can see there's going to be
different degrees of variation certainly
the most popular is going to be the kind
of anti-discrimination law or barring a
employer or life insurance company from
ever using this kind of data okay good
so let's go to the econometrics and our
sis and as promised it's going to be
relatively straightforward we are going
to simply report results from a linear
probability model though this
generalizes of course for more
appropriate functional forms on but it's
easier to understand the linear
probability model so the dependent
variable is whether or not the patient
gets a genetic tests in that time period
if they live in a state um we are going
to relate that to the genetic privacy
policy which was an effects in that
state at that time I whether or not
there was a more general health privacy
policy specific state in the time over
people's medical records and all these
saw demographics and care and also the
state characteristics which you might
think could affect the legal regime
that's in their state at that time so
sort of think of seeing think of the
regression is that and of course we have
state estate and fixed effects for these
three years okay so let's go to these
initial results and I'm just going to
ask how easily can you see this table
cuz I have a bigger version people are
back okay okay good okay we'll just sort
of walk through that in the big table um
and let's just sort of focus this is
where we sort of look at it separately
but let's focus on this which is when
you run them all together and reflect
the fact that a state can have different
sort of permutations or combinations of
different laws so what you're going to
see there is that the J consent law this
giving people information about how
their data could is going to be used
potentially has a negative effect on
people's decision to have a test
and the speaker it's a reasonably large
negative effect on the
anti-discrimination law which has been
at the forefront of all federal policy
has absolutely no measurable statistical
effect re disclosure laws that's what I
call some more pop see lights approach
where the patient is actually told that
this data will not be we disclose to
anyone without your permission um that
is going to have a positive effect on
the decision to have a law and haha it's
such a beautiful table hello there we go
wonderful to the rescue wonderful that
is just amazing right usually this
uneasy of course oh so the five columns
basically is where we look at the effect
of any one aspect of a law in isolation
and so you can SWAT you what you will
see there is that in general you see
that these consent regulations has a
negative effect and we don't measure too
much precisely for the other ones in
combination and and then when we get to
the final column what you see is that
the positive the positive effect we see
from redisclosure happens only really in
combination with consent laws that's
what you can infer from this that if you
give people information about how their
data is going to be used potentially
giving them control over who the chain
of custody of that data that's when we
see the positive effect so we don't have
is that I would interpret it the way you
just discovered it is an interaction
yeah so okay things are correlated with
each other yep and that only once you
control for the correlation you see the
partial effect so that that is maybe
that is the exactly the right way of
thinking of column 5 I try to tease it
apart with interaction effects so figure
this is a simplified form which sort of
tells that story right arm good what you
see in general the other persistent
results in general you get is suffer
having a baseline health privacy door in
place seems to have a positive effect on
the decision to have any genetic tests
um so if we went go and look at the
other variables they are somewhat as you
might expect or maybe in some sense
maybe there's also surprises about what
is not statistically significant but
being a female really matters that's
what you might expect given the efficacy
of the different genetic tests for
different cancers um in black seems to
have a significant effect which may
again reflect genetic distance in
genetic does it did with his positions
or perceived as reserve vulnerability to
cancer diagnosis um having no insurance
weekly has a negative effect but in
general one thing I'll say for the
economist's is that we were expecting
given the state of the literature for
insurance regime or the insurance have a
far bigger effect than it did because
all the economic models in this space
have been thinking about the
implications of genetic data for
insurance choices and instead what we're
really just measuring there's a small
weak effect of having no insurance yes
so in cases where people are saying yes
I'll take the tests are they also
getting counseling since then so the
best we're going to get from the survey
data we have is just really this
question about your insurance and I
think you can sort of we assume that
never happens with no insurance but one
thing that which some surprised me is
that having well maybe it doesn't
surprise more economist but you know we
don't see the positive effect from
having private insurance and the emitted
variable here which i guess is more
weakly positive as having some kind of
government sponsored insurance yes so do
you think about this is Los having an
effect because because specifically
about genetics or is it just an added
transaction costs like you know I'm
let's say like I have to send in this
the sting and whenever I session
biological materials some states have a
law that requires me to fill in a
special Xbox one and then that sort of
is cumbersome okay so we're gonna
actually try I'm going to try and give
you some evidence on that in that I
think most of the transaction costs
who's going to bear them it's going to
be the hospital and that's going to
influence the decision of the hospital
to even be offering or promoting these
tests and I'm going to run these same
regressions looking at hospitals
decisions to give genetic tests in in a
few slides time but you know if he knows
exactly right that's the sort of
alternative explanation which is not
consumer or patient centric yes sense of
these numbers I mean I see lots of zeros
yeah simple weird have been shocking to
see the first digit after the decimal
point being 14 it would be hugely
shocking because remember the dependent
variable here is 0.005 I'm almost
worried that some of these numbers are
too big and if i can so translate this
what we're seeing here and which is why
I'm worried about it that i'm going to
present you some issuing evidence later
on is that this bump is own is nearly
equivalent to the positive shock that
angelina jolie going around talking
about these tests had
the national rate Katherine I would run
this like as a baseline specification in
blogs rather than a linear probability
model any apology other thing is that
like that's going to approximate what a
loge it's gonna look like anyway and
it's gonna be easier for people to
interpret because then it's percent
increases okay maybe we could do we
could I think we could probably do that
fine specification ya know that we could
definitely do that yeah that's was like
yeah cuz I I mean I think one issue is
we got such a small dependent variable
this looks small whereas I'm wearing it
so big fifty percent more likely to dig
the business so that's roughly what
we're seeing from this baseline
specification stars statistical
significance yes so that I should have
said this so Armand footnote to table so
think of that as three stars is one
percent two stars is by presented in
comics of economics language and then
because we're not by statisticians we
give ourselves ten percent which is one
star yes can you tell us maybe out of
curiosity what is the variation in the
adoption of these loads to state like a
dub or four of them at once or states
get the first one and then they don't
get the other one or okay so one week
where we see I'll tell you where we see
most states have some kind of anti
discrimination and one of the reasons
they're going to have that especially
towards the end of this period is
because the federal government is going
to do something the variation we see is
very experiments in changes in weather
you just have informed consent or
whether you combine that with some
degree of disclosure control yeah so
thats anyway most of the variation is
coming from and that might be some
reason why you think having successful
in significance for anti-discrimination
you could explain maybe we could have
more variation of data okay any more
questions
good okay okay so I think I said we'll
listen words um we didn't I one thing I
should have highlighting so he was sort
of buried is nothing we will measure the
state level seem to affect average state
level okay so this you know being a
typical paper of this type we are going
to do a lot of robustness checks you
know using different ways of paralyzing
the controls one thing we're going to
worry about is exactly how you code this
change in federal law we're going to do
that too we're going to do some
functional form things arm rather linear
probability model that we haven't tried
that idea it's good one and nothing much
changes um I'll show you nothing much
really changes um but I've been more
interesting as this question sort of
what really what really a wee
hypothesizing could be going on to
explain seeing these effects which team
you know large and silver set the
incremental terms um so I think I'm
going to make my argument based on
actually showing you some of these
consent forms that people would go and
see during these sort of genetic testing
lab is this counseling and we're going
to start off is on the best examples but
they're different sort of types of
genetic testing consent forms and I want
to highlight to you this particular one
and this language which is what I would
say is an example of pure consent solid
working and you say by my secrets below
i hereby consent to poker elemental
ethics and it's responsible delegated
institutions or repositories to user
disclose my individually identifiable at
medical information including without
limitation all genetic information right
whether whether or not it and that's one
of them you remember I was saying the
way they phrased it in these consent
forms isn't particular to the particular
tests that you just had for purposes of
my diagnosis and treatment are to seek
payment from third parties and to
conduct ongoing health care
operations i ministered oversight
quality assurance control and technical
innovations so I would challenge you to
think really of what this the statement
is actually operating in terms of the
future use of the genetic data instead
the wording seems to be designed to give
as much wiggle room as possible we
shouldn't to give it to third parties
like insurance like they say life
insurers that's not for the purposes of
getting a reimbursement ok ok so again
how would you sort of think of a
responsible delegated institution again
it seems to me I think often the word in
these things is loose enough but it's
not quite clear when you say an
associates who does that really mean
right so I pink this sort of a a lot of
wiggle room is often baked into these
things I just want to sort of compare
this with the wording you might see in a
consent form which actually gives you
some degree of property rights um which
where you'd have a statement to say the
test was also be communicated to being
me at me by my positional genetic
counselor in a confidential manner and
will not be released to another party of
out my signed consent unless required by
law right so far more definitive
statement which potentially gives I
think a greater perception of control
how the privacy forms presented to the
we're gonna use somebody walks in
through nurs and here's a stack of
papers just like it I'm going in for my
MRI I just signed ya know it is so this
a little bit different in that they do
have these genetic counseling sex
sessions where they devote half an hour
to walking you through these forms now
the extent to which they do a good job I
have no information but it's not the
case you just sort of woke me up the
reception desk and be presented these
forms they're really sort of trying to
make sure that at least meant to be
trying to make sure you understand
okay so it's a slightly unusual actually
privacy context right because usually
when we sort of examine privacy policies
it's far more of the sort of just tick
the box get this out the way but here
they're actually trying to explain them
yes you're the same is true with a part
of the American general directive which
then what happens to it now that I mean
I think that seems true right I mean
what I would say is that I think all of
us can see potential negative
consequences still from this statement
but does it feel better than the first
statement yes it feels better so I sort
of think there's a feeling better more
control rather than you know necessarily
being a complete contract shall we say
yes a lot of negative context to the
sort of sorry negative consequence the
sort of statement with regard to
research diagnosing familial breast
cancer from bracket sequence is actually
still really hard and they're all these
companies that do it and they have their
own my case control data sets all
completely siloed and they sort of want
to keep them siloed for selfish business
interest they serve hide behind these
sometimes of excuse it's a little this
little gray there as well yeah no I mean
I think so here in the first one I
showed you who you can definitely see
technical innovations perhaps being a
compass said that it's going to go on
and be part of one of these data silos
potentially I you know as an aside it
might see contradictory given this paper
we're trying to write another paper at
the moment which is arguing that we're
going too far because we're so worried
about come here is that 23andme that
we're not language to make the searchers
to actually look at these kind of data
but I think it's a concern and certainly
this kind of blanket statement would
make it hard to actually use them in the
record for medical research purposes but
for a patient perhaps that's reassuring
idea
okay now this goes back to the
transaction costs question which every
was exactly right which is so I just saw
a given you my thesis of what's going on
which is a people we need to read these
forms and that one set of forms sort of
emphasize your powerlessness and all the
bad things that can happen and then as
well said so for set of forms which give
you more of a sense of control however
there could be something else entirely
different going on which is more of a
transaction costs but these regulations
are going to impose different costs on
hospitals arm and maybe that can just
explain the effect we're not really
seeing any consumer differences and say
it's just an artifact of a hospital
availability ok so the way what we're
measuring is a genetic testing facility
localized within a hospital that's this
kind of genetic testing and all the
counseling tends to take place in the
hospital I'm sure maybe they are maybe
they offer it to save them cuz i'm not
sure but most of the operations
procedures diagnosis counseling taking
place in the hospital is considered
impossible yeah yes it doesn't have to
work the hospital didn't see that you
know if you ask you to fill in five four
hundred hundred I'm gonna do it it just
um I mean it does you know cookies some
form that i have to call you up say that
yeah i mean i think my only answer for
that if it was really the case that just
small paper is just off-putting I don't
have such a good explanation about why
we see the positive effects from giving
people more control right I mean I think
my texts or think of it is doing a
baseline negative effect that's but I
can't explain the positive effect
so I'll just show you quickly this was
regression and this is where we run the
same regression well we've entirely
changed the data set in the background
and change what the dependent variable
is and the dependent variable is now
going to be whether an individual
hospital has embraced the genetic
testing facility and this is we're using
an American Hospital Association data
here or where the hospital system
potentially has adopted at this kind of
genetic testing facility and we're going
to use the same variation laws and what
we're going to find is the same negative
effect and consent arm and so that
suggests that well then it just beam us
or powerlessness I was suggesting I
think part of the result is going to be
some kind of transaction cost
explanation that having this extra sore
burden of getting consent and so on is
going to be off-putting to a hospital
because you're gonna have to have the
legal expertise and a parallel system
and ways of storing will do these kind
of things um what I want you to notice
though is that we don't have any
positive effects anymore though from
this redisclosure ball arm and if
anything it seems to be slightly
negative and that might be for the
reasons you suggest why might I have a
genetic testing facility potentially
because then I can draw a search as to
my hospital uses data become famous all
these kind of things and the genetic
come the genetic with disclosure law has
sort of stops that process now isn't
significant so I'm entirely just off
interpolating from her since the
internet weakened coefficient is
interesting it's in a different
direction so I think you know the main
thing I have against a redisclosure part
at least being an artifact of
transaction costs is that we're not
seeing it having the sort of you know
we're not seeing so many effects on
Hospital decision that seems instead to
be working through on their patients
though certainly the consent law does
seem to have some negative effects on
hospitals decisions and if you sort of
compare coefficient to coefficient and
so do some back-of-the-envelope
calculations is probably explaining at
least half of the effect the hospitals
are put off from adopting these systems
yes couldn't there be some sort of
feedback where the hospital is less
likely because it thinks the patients
are less likely to say yes yeah no I
mean and this is very reduced form with
absolutely you looks one thing I'm
always asked is well why don't you
combine this and it's precisely because
I don't want to sort overstate how much
we can sorties a part about what's
driving the two decisions I don't really
have any instruments here one of the
baseline rates look like um oh I should
add that cystic there from men where
it's around twenty percent so another
other regressions I met you also it's
lower than I swear cycle that box right
eight percent less yeah it's you can you
do you do sort of free trend sort of
testing yeah I mean we again I think
that's exactly right and we've tried to
do it for free data points it always
just looks a little bit pathetic um you
know we you know if it takes slow enough
published a paper maybe we'll have 2015
and then will you know have at least
four we know I mean I think I think
certainly one drawback is the usual
things you'd like to see in a paper like
this like pre trend you know we can't go
back further because you know these
testament would exist and you know we I
guess we can just wait a long time to
get published right yeah that's hurry up
a solution quite good at that there yes
so I'm to remember what the state of the
bracket testing business was like 2003
or 2010 if i recall correctly there's a
single company Myriad Genetics at a
patent on these two genes mm-hmm this
Padma struck down by Supreme Court yeah
but so how much this is hospital
switched hospitals choosing whether to
offer tests and how much of this is like
this one company deciding where to send
its sales people
okay so that's really interesting um I
mean obviously we're going to catch that
sort of baseline change with you know
Heidi Williams some wonderful works or
studying the effects of that we're going
to catch that the ufx to a certain
extent after your period of date yeah
I'm just trying to understand um yeah
I'm just also when I make sure you say
that I'm wondering if it's some kind of
instrument I could be using here it
could be possibly um their sales data if
there was even of course it you know
their right to do that or maybe you
could some to have some type of home
based educational bondage or something
like that I'm not sure I mean what I
think what we can I don't know if you
remember those figures but at the
beginning at 2000 we at point zero point
four percent by the end with points6 of
a percent it suggests to me that they
had a stranglehold if you arrive they
had a stronghold at the beginning we
haven't seen even too much entry during
this period right it's not the case has
been this huge increases through getting
repairs the supreme court case in 2013
yeah you do 10 2010 it ends in 2010 so
that's again interesting yeah yeah yeah
again you see everywhere saying don't
ever published gets more instruments you
can actually maybe identify some of
these things sacrifice but okay um you
know I've got ten minutes left and it's
10 minutes right yeah okay so the rest
of paper is I was so sad tongue-in-cheek
is then goes exactly in the way you
would expect and economics reduced form
paper to do in that we're going to show
this absolutely no effect where you want
to expect it and there is a stronger
effect where you would expect a song
effect um so what we did first of all
was sort of worried a bit about where
well you know these state laws we think
Nestle driven by individual state
legislators but what if there are other
things going on the state which can
explain them and also explain changes in
genetic testing rates and we were
worried about two things Ortiz we
identify two things first thing well
maybe they reflect something about
underlying health privacy or taste the
health privacy and so what we did was we
used a dependent variable which is
whether or not you've ever had an HIV
test and so well how was that influenced
by these different genetic laws and we
show that when you have none genetic
data she proposed that if you're willing
that you spend the last ten minutes
talking about other things you're
interested in on privacy and you know
what what else like interest you beyond
this rather than going into sort of like
you know all okay the usual thanks
checks because that's fine I just think
for this audience it'll be okay good
good well as I say if you are a useful
Makana magician all the stuff is there
you'd expect we have the falsification
checks um we also show it's going to be
you're not going to see in effect for
people who have already had cancer
because the bad news is out and we're
going to show these effects are
strongest for people who have a the
biggest potential having bad news from
the chapter test so you know as I say
this is so a study of health privacy
information the first one at least to
try and do something like this about
individual decision-making relating its
state laws and what we find is that
giving over people control actually
seems have a positive effect on
decision-making and this is particularly
so people are worried about bad news um
on the other hand are typical of in a
very I think legalistic approach which
is all informed consent we see a
deterrence effect both the patient level
and the hospital life and all these some
data usage policies which has been a big
focus of government policy arm end up
having absolutely no effect and you know
whether that's good news or bad news
depends on your prior about how damaging
most regulation is okay
so I think glenn wants me so get here
sort of think about where is this all
going right and why do I think it's
important well it's important because i
think is a far broader set of questions
which take us away from our focus on
thinking about advertising and privacy
about thinking about well how do we
regulate for future selves that is a
self for 10 20 years ahead given the
persistence of digital data on our lack
of ability about how to think about the
technology okay so that's so general
FISA sand one way you could sort of
think of this question has been
motivated is that in my prior research I
looked a lot at advertising privacy we
work I'm very proud on and i continued I
think I have in retrospect in somewhat
frustrated that so much of the policy
debate has focused on privacy concerns
relating to advertising simply because
they're the short-term news is a
short-term effect maybe it's a verte
maybe it so for putting maybe it's
creepy at the time but there don't seem
to be the more negative long-term
consequences of digital data and so this
is an attempt or start to think well
what's the real sore privacy concern I
have for deeply as an economist is what
we're now creating a permanent digital
record of ourselves something we've
never really experienced before how do
we regulate for that and so it's all
trying to go why I thought they're
harmless most severe the other piece of
work that I'd like to highlight just
because it's a something that someone
actually have microsoft research in
Cambridge has also thought about is
government surveillance and this is
again add attempt to try and move the
discussion away from privacy and
advertising to think about other ways we
might worry about abba term about the
digital future and privacy and in this
research what we do is
we look to see how the Edward Snowden
revelations affected people's behavior
on Google friends and it's a very very
simple paper you might think this was
complex econometrics let me tell you we
get even more simple those really will
bar charts and what we show in that
paper is that in general the in the US
the changes in searches you see are
really simply on words which might mark
you out as a terrorist so people stop
starts you on anthrax they start
searching on pipe bomb right you
definitely see that arm so it seems in
some sense abused me to be rational
response um on the other hand
internationally that is and this is what
internationally has been defined as US
is top 10 trading partners what we find
there is that searches yes you still got
people searching a bit less a pipe on
but instead we see a drop in searches
for a formal personal kind of privacy
protection in that we see people
stopping searching on anorexia stopping
searching on various medical conditions
stopping searching on bankruptcy all
these kind of things we might think of
as personally embarrassing rather than
just stuff it will give us in trouble
for the repair for development and so
based on these results so he then drew a
while the grandiose policy conclusion
which is that well we often think of
surveillance is just simply being you
know something for our political
scientist friends to worry about but
actually potentially commercial economic
effects from various governments
surveillance policies so that some sort
of other work I wanted to highlight and
I'm highlighting it just simply because
I know there's been a researcher at
Microsoft and he actually looked at just
us data and didn't find much i think you
know he's using bing way where this
actually market share sits or makes
sense right you look at the US but it
does make sense to me given that mostly
affects we saw where actually
internationally web perhaps so have you
got you have to use google down ok then
was that what you were wanting me to do
is interested where you're good where
are you like what other stuff are you
doing on privacy what's your agenda on
this you know ya know so really so I
think you know as an economist you
always saw strength I was trying to step
aside from being too grandiose about my
ambitions but I think you know I think
the two papers I've described as typical
of where I'm going now which is trying
to think well all the areas that perhaps
we've studied less which might matter
more in the future so that would be my
sub grand statement of where I'm going
thank you very much of course have you
thought about or looked at at all
adoption so genetic information is a
substitute in a way for knowing your
family history have you looked at
controlling for how well people know
their own family history well that's a
really nice idea the furthest we got is
that if you have a family history with
bad cancer in it the effect of the laws
tend to be more pronounced the zoom lee
because you're worried more worried
about that you're going to have a bad
test at all but we did they don't we
just don't have the data or adoption but
at such a cool idea he can actually
allow him who's going and you speak
wonderful of course
what